in the u.s we don't directly vote for
our president or vice president instead
we use something called the electoral
college
the electoral college so when you show
up to vote on election day an election
day will happen in november of an
election year and it could happen as
early as november 2nd and it could
happen as late as november 8th and it's
going to be the tuesday after the first
monday in the month so it'll be november
2nd if the first monday mo if the first
monday is november 1st and it'll be
november 8th if the first monday is
november 7th and so you go on election
day and you will see a ballot that'll
have the presidential candidates that'll
have their parties there it'll have the
vice presidential candidates and you'll
vote for one of them but in actuality
when you're voting for
when you're voting for candidate
candidate a and let's say candidate a is
a democrat you're not actually voting
for candidate a you're actually voting
for a for a slate of electors who
promise to vote for that candidate so
you electors for
for that candidate and it isn't in most
states proportional based on what
proportion of people vote for one
candidate or another it's in most of the
states except for maine and nebraska it
is a winner-take-all system so what do i
mean by that
so right here i the you have the
breakdown in the united states by state
of how many electors each state gets and
the number of electors is essentially
the number of congressmen that that
state has for example california has two
senators every state has two senators
california has two senators and 53
congressmen and those of you who aren't
familiar with it every state gets two
senators and the congressman or the
the house of representatives is dictated
by population california is a huge state
two senators 53 representatives
you have texas two senators and it has
32 representatives you go to louisiana
you have two senators and you have seven
representatives so the electors per
state is based on the total number of
congressmen so the number of senators
plus the number of representatives
that's what gives us 55 in california
nine in louisiana 34 in texas but what's
interesting here is it's a winner take
all system in every state except for
nebraska and maine in every other state
if i get 51 percent of the vote in texas
i get all 34 electoral votes in the
electoral college if i get 51 or even if
i get 50.1 percent just a slight
majority of the votes in california i
will get all of the votes for california
in the electoral college and in general
or in actuality the president whoever is
whoever gets the majority of the the
electoral votes in the united states and
right now that threshold is or that
magic number you could think of it that
way is 270
electoral
electoral college votes electoral
college votes if no candidate is able to
hit this threshold of 270 electoral
college votes then it will go to the u.s
congress and in the u.s congress it's
interesting because it isn't one
congressman one vote or actually i
should say the u.s house of
representatives it'll go to the u.s
house of representatives and it won't be
one representative one vote what will
happen is the representatives in each
state will vote together
and each state will get only one vote so
in a tiebreaker the big states really
really lose out because in the
tiebreaker texas will get only one vote
california will get one vote and alaska
will get one vote and rhode island will
get one vote so rhoda the
rhode island will have just as much say
in a tiebreaker as california will over
who will be president and they'll just
keep voting until someone gets a simple
majority of the votes by state now
there's one other twist here is that the
district of columbia washington dc right
over here in congress gets no
representatives they have no senators
and they have no representatives but
they do get three electoral votes when
it comes to deciding who is going to be
president
now you might already be getting a sense
you have a sense here that maybe this
winner-take-all system might lead to
some distortions and the biggest
distortion of all is you can imagine a
candidate who wins who wins the popular
vote
who wins the popular vote and loses
and loses the election or loses in the
electoral college
and you might think well gee how does
you know how can that happen
and the way to think about it is imagine
someone let's say someone gets with the
states that they win they get huge
majorities so let's say there's a
conservative candidate they get and he
or she gets huge majorities in the
states they win 80 percent in texas they
get eighty percent mississippi they get
eighty percent in oklahoma they get huge
majorities in the states that they win
and the states that they lose they
barely lose and they barely lose those
really big states so let's say in
florida you that congress or that that
candidate i should say gets 49 percent
of the vote so they had a lot of votes
in florida but not enough to win it the
other person let's say gets 51 percent
all 27 go to the other candidate let's
say the same thing happens in let's say
the same thing happens in california
that candidate got 49 percent of the
vote the opponent let's say gets 51
percent of the vote all 55 go to
california you get no credit for that 49
percent you get no credit for that 49
percent in florida so in this situation
this candidate might actually end up
with the majority barely losing the
states they lose and trouncing the other
candidate in the states that they win
but despite that actually getting fewer
electoral college votes now there's a
few clarifications i want to make
especially ones that that have confused
me in the past one of them is
because you have the same number of
electoral college votes as you have
us representatives plus senators there's
kind of this feeling that maybe each
each district sends its own elector to
the state capitol decide who president
is and it doesn't quite work that way so
this right here is the panel of electors
for louisiana in 2008 and you can see
right over here each of the parties each
of the parties have their own slate of
electors and these are used either
decided by the party themselves or
they're decided by the the candidates
teams and even though you know you have
a j you have someone here for each
district and then you have these at
large candidates it's not like let's
take a situation and this actually
happened in louisiana where john mccain
got a majority of the state so john
mccain and sarah palin got a majority of
the state it's not the case that let's
say let's say in the second district
which which represent which is new
orleans let's say that the second
district a majority of the people
actually voted for barack obama it is
not the case that kenneth garrett in
2008 would have been the chosen elector
it is a actually even though they divide
things by district and they have these
at large candidates it is actually a
statewide election so they don't look at
who won each of the districts they just
say look
john mccain and sarah palin won the
entire state so all of these electors
all of these electors are the ones that
are going to go to the state capitol in
december and decide who they want to
pledge their vote for so even if even if
obama won just the second congressional
district that's not how it's thought
about in the electoral college it's just
a statewide election mccain got the
majority of the state all of the
electors will be chosen from mccain
slate or from the republican party slate
and then they're going to go to the
state capitol in the case of louisiana
it would be baton rouge and they will
decide who they want to pledge their
votes to and all of the electors in all
of the states go to their designated
location usually the state capitol on
the same day and usually that is some
day in december and they pick the
present although by that point everyone
knows who the president is because the
actual election was in early november
and people know which way the votes went
and which way the actual electoral
college votes went
now i did mention that there are two
states that don't do this winner take
all nebraska and maine and in nebraska
and maine when you go vote it really is
by congressional district nebraska has
three congressional districts so in
those three congressional districts if
one of them goes to the democrat and two
goes to the republican then they'll have
one electoral vote for the democrat and
two for the republican and then they
have two at-large votes that are decided
the same way in kind of the
winner-take-all basis if you get 51
percent of the vote on a statewide basis
you get the two at-large votes same
thing for maine but maine has two
congressional districts so two of the
congressional districts could go either
way and then the at-large are based on a
state-wide vote now you can imagine the
other kind of unfair thing here other
than the popular vote versus the you
know the electoral college vote is it
you could imagine it makes some some
states better represented than others so
if you just divide if you just divide
population by the number of electors you
see the larger states each elector is
representing many many more people this
is california right here each elector is
representing over 600 000 people and in
the smaller states this is wyoming right
here each elector is representing under
thousand per
under two hundred thousand people so in
wyoming people are getting kind of three
times the representation as they would
in california on a per capita vote what
makes it even a little bit more skewed
because it's winner take all and the
candidates aren't silly and they want to
make sure that they spend their money
and their visits and their time in the
most leverageable way it actually
creates this weird scenario where
candidates will often ignore huge parts
of the population and they ignore them
because those huge parts of the
population are unlikely to swing one way
or the other so for example california
is very reliably democratic and
texas is very reliably republican
so this right here this is a fascinating
graph at least in my mind it shows where
george bush george w bush and john kerry
spent the last five weeks of their of of
the 2004 election let me close that
right there of the 2004 election
this top graph shows where they actually
spent their time so each of these little
hands here is a visit in those final
five weeks and each of these dollar
signs is a million dollars spent on
marketing and advertising in on ads and
whatever else in those states and you
can see california and texas the two
biggest states they didn't spend enough
money to threshold to get a dollar sign
written there so they didn't even spend
a million dollars on these huge states
they only they only had a few visits to
california
and texas
texas had no visits in the final five
weeks so what happens is that candidates
spend a disproportionate amount of
attention and money in the states that
are more likely to swing one way or
another so the people in florida
or in ohio so this is ohio and florida
got a ton of more attention at least
especially on a per person basis than
the people in texas did